can you explain your view on power in
international Politics as outlined in
your book The Tragedy of great power
politics and in your writing since then
yeah I make two sets of points there
first of all I believe that power is the
currency of international relations and
by that I mean that states are deeply
interested in the balance of power and
they're interested in maximizing how
much power they control and the question
is why States care so much about power
in the International System there's no
higher authority so if you get into
trouble and you dial 911 there's nobody
at the other end in a system like that
you have no choice but to figure out for
yourself how best to protect yourself
and the best way to protect yourself is
to be powerful to have as much power as
you can possibly gain over all the other
states in the system therefore States
care about power because it enhances or
maximizes their prospects for survival
second point I would make is that in the
real story or in my story power is
largely a function of material factors
uh the two ke key building blocks of
Power are population size and wealth you
want to have a lot of people and you
want to be really wealthy of course this
is why the United States is so powerful
it has lots of people and it has lots of
wealth China was not considered a great
power until
recently uh because it didn't have a lot
of wealth certainly had population size
but it didn't have wealth and without
both a large population and much wealth
you're usually not considered a great
power uh so I I think power matters uh
but uh when we talk about power it's
important to understand that it's uh
population size and wealth that are
underpinning it so there's a lot of
interesting things there first you said
nations in relation to each other are is
essentially in a state of anarchism yeah
well Anarchy basically means the
opposite of hierarchy sometimes people
think when you're talking about Anarchy
you're talking about murder and mayham
but that's not what Anarchy means in the
realist context Anarchy simply means
that you don't have hierarchy there's no
higher authority that sits above States
states are like pool balls on a table
right and in an anarchic world uh
there's no higher authority that you can
turn to uh if you get into trouble and
of course the political philosopher who
laid made this all out was Thomas Hobbs
and Hobbs talked about life in the state
of nature and in the state of nature you
have
individuals and those individuals
compete with each other for power and
the reason that they do is because in
the state of nature by definition you
have no higher authority and hobbs' view
is that the way to get out of this
terrible situation where individuals are
competing with each other and even
killing each other is create a state
it's what he calls the Leviathan and
that of course is the title of his
famous book so the idea is to escape
Anarchy you create a state and that
means you go from Anarchy to hierarchy
the problem in international politics is
that there is no world State there is no
hierarchy and if you have no hierarchy
and you're in an anarchic system you
have no choice
but to try to maximize your relative
power to make sure you are as we used to
say when I was a kid on New York City
playgrounds the biggest and baddest dude
on the Block not because you necessarily
want to beat up on other kids or on
other states but because again that's
the best way to survive and as I like to
point out to people the best example of
what happens when you're weak in
international politics is what the
Chinese called the century of national
humiliation from the late 1840s to the
late 1940s the Chinese were remarkably
weak and the great powers in the system
prayed upon them and uh that sends a
very important message to not only the
Chinese but to other states in the
system don't be weak be as powerful as
you can and we'll talk about it but
humiliation can lead to resentment and
resentment leads to uh something you've
also studied which is Nazi Germany in
the 19 30s we'll talk about it um but
staying to the psychology and philosophy
picture what's the connection between
the will to power in the individual as
you mentioned and the will to power in a
nation the will to power in an
individual has a lot to do with
individual psychology uh the story that
I tell about the pursuit of power is a
structural argument it's an argument
that says when you are in a particular
structure when you're in a system that
has a specific
architecture which is
anarchy the states have no choice but to
compete for power uh so structure is
really driving the story here Will To
Power has a lot more to do with an
individual uh in in the nichan story
where that concept comes from so it's
very important to understand that I'm
not arguing that states are inherently
aggressive right my point is that as
long as states are in Anarchy right they
have no choice but to behave in an
aggressive fashion but if you went to a
hierarchic system uh there's no reason
for those states to worry about the
balance of power because if they get
into trouble there is a higher authority
that they can turn to there is an effect
the Leviathan so what is the role of
military might in this uh will to power
on the national level well military
might's what ultimately matters as I
said to you before the two building
blocks of Power are population size and
wealth you didn't mention military I did
not no that's right and it's good that
you caught that because if you have a
large population and you're a wealthy
country what you do is you build a large
military and it's ultimately the size of
your military that matters uh because
militaries fight Wars and if states are
concerned about survival which I argue
is the principal goal of every state in
the International System for what I
think are obvious reasons then they're
going to care about having a powerful
military that can protect them if
another state comes after them what's
not obvious that a large Nation with a
lot of people and a lot of money should
necessarily build a gigantic Army and
seek to attain
superpower like dominant sole superpower
status to military might but you're
saying as you see the world today it has
to be that way yeah I'm arguing it is
obvious if you're a state in the
International System uh do you want to
be weak uh if you live next door to Nazi
Germany or imperial Germany or
Napoleonic France or even the United
States the United States is a ruthless
great power you surely recognize that
and if you're dealing with the United
States of America and you're Vladimir
Putin you want to make sure you're as
powerful as possible so that the United
States doesn't put its gun s sits on you
and come after you same thing is true
with China you want to be powerful in
the International System States
understand that and they go to Great
Lengths to become powerful just take the
United States America when it started in
1783 it was comprised of 13 measly
colonies strung out along the Atlantic
Seaboard over time you know the uh
various leaders of the United States
went to Great Lengths to turn that
country into the dominant power in the
Western Hemisphere and then once that
was achieved in 1900 we've gone to Great
Lengths to make sure that there's no
peer uh competitor in the system uh we
just want to make sure that we're number
one uh and my argument is that this is
not peculiar to the United
States uh if I'm China for example
today I would want to dominate Asia the
way the United States dominates the
Western Hemisphere they'd be fools not
to if I were Imperial Germany I'd want
to dominate all of Europe the way the
United States dominates the Western
Hemisphere why because if you dominate
all of Europe assuming your Imperial
Germany or Napoleonic France then no
other state in the area or in the region
can threaten you because you're simply
so powerful uh and again what I'm saying
here is that the structure of the
International System really matters it's
the fact that you're in this anarchic
system where survival is your principal
goal and where I can't know your
intentions right you're another state I
can't know that at some point you might
not come after me you might and if
you're really powerful and I'm not I'm
in deep trouble yeah so some of the
ideas underlying what you've said uh
offensive realism which I would love to
talk to you about sort of the history of
realism versus liberalism but some of
the ideas you already mentioned uh
Anarchy between
states everybody's try develop a
military capabilities uncertainty such
an interesting concept uh States cannot
be sure that other states will not use
military capabilities against them which
is that's of enormous importance story
and so interesting because you also say
that this makes realists more cautious
and more
peaceful the
uncertainty because of all the
uncertainty involved here it's better to
approach International Poli politics
with
caution is really interesting to think
about uh again survival most States
interested in survival and the other
interesting thing is you assume all the
states are
rational um which most of the time most
of the time you call this framework
offensive realism C can you just give a
overview of the history of the realism
versus liberalism debate as World Views
well I think for many centuries now the
big
divide uh within the world of
international relations
theory is between realism and liberalism
these are time honored bodies of theory
and before I tell you what I think the
differences are between those two bodies
of theory it is important to emphasize
that there are differences among
realists and differences among
liberals um and uh so when you talk
about me as an offensive realist you
should understand that there are also
defensive realists out there and there
are uh a panoply of liberal theories as
well but uh basically realists believe
that power matters that states compete
for power and that war is an instrument
of
statecraft and uh uh uh liberals on the
other hand have what I would say is a
more idealistic view of the world uh
this is not to say that they're naive or
foolish but they believe there are
aspects of international
politics uh that lead to a less
competitive and more peaceful world than
most realists
see uh and I'll lay out for you very
quickly what are the three major liberal
theories today that I think will give
you a sense of the more optimistic
perspective that is inherent in the
liberal
Enterprise uh the first and most
important of the liberal theories is
democratic peace Theory and this is a
theory that says democracies do not
fight against other
democracies so the more the world world
is populated with democracies the less
likely it is that we will have
wars uh and this basic argument is
inherent in Francis fukiyama the end of
History he argues that democracy
triumphed first over fascism in the 20th
century it then triumphed over communism
and that means that in the future we're
have more and more liberal democracies
on the planet and if you have more and
more liberal democracies and those
democracies don't fight each other then
you have a more peaceful world that was
his argument it's a very liberal
argument a realist like me would say
that it doesn't matter whether a state
is a democracy or not all states behave
the same way because the structure of
the system getting back to our earlier
discussion about International Anarchy
the structure of the system leaves those
States no choice whether they're
democracies or autocracies and again the
liberal view this first liberal theory
is that democracies don't fight other
democracies and therefore the more
democracies you have the more peaceful
the world can I just uh sort of try to
unpack that a little bit so on the
Democratic peace Theory I guess would
say that in democracies leaders are
elected and the underlying assumption is
most most people want peace and so they
will elect peacemakers so the more you
democracies you have the more likely you
have peace and then the realist
perspective what says that it doesn't
matter if the majority of people want
peace the
structure of international politics is
such that superpowers want to become
more Super and powerful and they do that
through War you can't make that argument
that you're making about democracies
because if you're saying that
democracies are inclined toward peace
and that the electorate picks leaders
who are inclined towards peace then you
have to show that democracies are in
general more peaceful than
non-democracies and you can't support
that argument you can find lots of
evidence to support the argument that
democracies don't fight other
democracies so the argument I believe
that you have to make if you're going to
support Democratic peace Theory the main
argument you have to make is that
liberal
democracies have a healthy respect for
each other and they can assess each
other's intentions if you're a liberal
democracy and I'm a liberal democracy we
know we have value systems that argue
against a R agression and argue for
peaceful resolution of Crisis and
therefore given these Norms we can trust
each other we can know each other's
intentions remember for realists like me
uncertainty about intentions really
helps Drive the train but if you're
talking about two
democracies right the argument there is
that they know each other's intentions
and for you sure maybe democracies
reduce uncertainty a little bit but not
enough to stop the train I think that's
right yeah that's that's right so that's
Democratic peace theory yes the second
theory is economic interdependence
Theory and that's the argument that in a
globalized world like the one that we
live in and have lived in for a long
time there's a great deal of economic
interdependence and if you and I are two
countries uh or if you and me are two
countries and we're economically
interdependent and we're both getting
prosperous as a result of this econom IC
intercourse the last thing that we're
going to do is start a war either one of
us because who would kill the goose that
lays the golden eggs it's that kind of
argument so there you have an argument
that economic interdependence leads to
peace and then the third liberal
argument has to do with
institutions uh sometimes referred to as
liberal institutionalism and this is the
argument that if you can get States into
institutions where they become rule
abiding
actors they will obey the rules that
dictate that war is not
acceptable uh so if you get them to
accept uh uh the UN rules on when you
can and cannot initiate a war uh then
you'll have a more peaceful world so
those are the liberal theories and as
you can tell they're very different from
realism as articulated by somebody like
me can you uh maybe argue against the
economic interdependence and in the
institutions that institutions follow
rules um a little bit so the the the
Golden Goose with the golden egg you're
saying that nations are happy to kill
the goose because again they want Power
if they think it's necessary to kill the
Golden Goose yeah because of security
concerns they will do it the point is
that economic
interdependence at its root has
Prosperity as the core variable yeah in
the realist story The Core variable is
survival and survival always trumps
Prosperity so if you go back to the
period before World War I we're in
Europe it's
1913 or early
1914 what you see is that you have an
intense security competition between all
of the great powers on one side you have
the Triple Alliance and on the other
side you have the triple onon you have
these two alliances and you have an
intense security competition between
them okay at the same time you have a
great deal of economic interdependence
it's amazing how much economic
intercourse is taking
place in Europe among all the actors
right and people are getting prosperous
or countries are getting prosperous as a
result but nevertheless in the famous
July crisis of
1914 this economic Prosperity is unable
to prevent World War I because security
concerns or survival is more important
uh so there are you know going to be
lots of situations where prosperity and
survival come in into conflict and in
those cases survival will win and uh
maybe you can speak to the different
camps of realists you said offensive and
defensive can you draw a distinction
between those two yeah let me just back
up a bit on that one and you were
talking about Will To Power before uh
the first big
divide between realists is structural
realists and human nature realists nice
and Hans
morganth who was influenced by nature
and
therefore had that willto power logic
embedded in his thinking about how the
world works right he was a human nature
realist okay I'm a structural
realist and I believe it's not human
nature it's it's not individuals and
some Will To Power that drives
competition and War what drives
competition and war is the structure of
the system it's Anarchy so you're not as
romantic as the human nature realists
yeah there's just a a world of
difference between the two sure it just
important to understand that so within
that from the structural that there's a
subdivision also of offensive and
defensive yes inside the structural
realist world right and you
have a handful of realists who believe
that the structure of the
system Fosters competition for sure
security competition but it really rules
out great power War almost all the time
so it makes sense to care about the
balance of power but to focus on
maintaining how much power you have
that's the def defensive realism
maintaining how much power you have not
trying to gain more power because the
argument the defensive realists make is
that if you try to gain more power the
system will punish you the structure
will punish
you I'm not a defensive realist I'm an
offensive realist and my argument is
that states look for
opportunities to gain more power and
every time they see or
almost every time they see an
opportunity to gain more power U and
they think the likelihood of success is
high and the cost will not be great
they'll jump at that
opportunity